[Music]
Hello, dear friends. Uh, welcome to our
program, I'd like to know, a question
and answer program where you send us
your questions and we do our best to do
the research and find answers to those
questions. Uh I'm Stephen Boore,
president of Secrets Unsealed and Some
TV. And for our program today, we have
two distinguished guests, uh good
friends and uh great researchers of
scripture. To my right hand, I have
Pastor Daniel Miranda, associate pastor
of Fresno Central Church, which I had
the privilege of pastoring for 20 years.
Great church.
If you're ever in the area, make sure
that you come and visit Fresno Central.
Amen. and it's a pleasure to have him.
Even though he is very busy there at
Fresno Central, he always helps us here
at Secrets on Seal. Thank you, Pastor
Miranda.
Thank you for inviting me, Pastor Bo.
You're welcome to be here.
And uh we have to my left hand uh David
Salasar, also very good friend, uh very
active here in the ministry. Uh he leads
uh everything having to do with our
Spanish work. And it's always great to
work with you, pastor.
Thank you, Pastor Bo. It's a blessing
and a privilege to be with you and with
Pastor Danielle.
Amen. If you do have questions, you can
send them to us uh at the following
email address, tvsumtv.org.
You'll see it on the screen,
tvsumtv.org.
Uh we might delay a while in answering
them because we receive many many
questions. Uh but uh be patient, keep on
tuning in and eventually we will get to
your question. uh we should never start
our uh study of scripture without prayer
and uh so I feel it's important as we
begin this program to pray. Pastor
Salasad, would you pray for us?
Absolutely. Let us pray.
Gracious heavenly father, we are so
thankful to you for the knowledge of
your word and for giving us the power
through the Holy Spirit to understand
all things. And we know that it is not
in ourselves that have the knowledge or
even the clarity to explain things, but
it is through the power and the grace of
your holy spirit. So we pray that you
will lead us into all truth and allow us
to present your word in a way that is
clear and that it will touch their
hearts and point our listeners to you,
the source of all wisdom and glory. We
pray this in Jesus name. Amen.
Amen.
Okay. You know, we uh have a third
question from our last program that we
didn't answer, but there's also uh a
question that uh that we did not answer
in relationship to to number two.
And uh so will there be a baptism at the
Sea of Glass? We didn't answer that
particular part.
Yeah, we mentioned it briefly, but we
didn't quite answer it.
If not, if not if there's not going to
be baptisms, why not?
Well, baptism, baptism is a sign, a
public declaration that now I have
repented for my sins and I have given my
life to Jesus. But we understand from
scripture that those who will be
standing on the sea of glass according
to Revelation 15:E2,
they have obtained the victory over the
beast, his image. In other words, they
keep the commandments of God. So there
is no need of baptisms in heaven
because we have already obtained victory
over sin and we have a glorified
sanctified body.
What about people who have not been
baptized here?
Well, that's a good question. Uh I think
uh the the blood of Jesus Christ will
cover that. And u
uh the bottom line is that we will be
eternally happy with Jesus. All of us
clothed with the righteousness of Jesus.
And the Bible assures us that sin will
never rise a second time.
So I believe there will not be need of
baptisms.
You know, many people excuse not being
baptized by the experience of the thief
on the cross,
right?
Uh they say, you know, the thief on the
cross was never baptized and Jesus said
that he's going to be in the kingdom.
And my always answer is you're not a
thief and you're not on a cross.
Absolutely. So uh so you know the fact
that uh that there will be people in the
kingdom who were never baptized because
of extenduating circumstances or because
baptism there was not water available or
for some other reason. Uh those
individuals will still be in the kingdom
and they still will be saved.
Amen.
But Jesus Christ got baptized for those
you know that could never be able to be
baptized due to certain circumstances.
that if you have a chance, if you are
able, you need to be baptized.
Amen.
You know, it is an important ceremony.
It's a command. A command.
Yes. Absolutely. Okay. The third
question which we did not answer last
time. Do we enter the gates of the new
Jerusalem in heaven according to the
similarities of the sins of the 12 sons
of Israel?
Well, I I think that one of the reasons
why this person is perhaps asking this
question is maybe through the fact that
he has been reading Revelation 17, I
mean Revelation 7 rather, where it
speaks about the
12,000 of each tribe describing them as
those that are, you know, in the kingdom
of heaven. And may maybe perhaps he has
heard a presentation or he has maybe
deduced that the fact is that these are
listed all the 12 tribes of of Israel
are listed as characteristics of those
who are in heaven and maybe he's he has
been explained or maybe the sermon of
whoever he heard or he studied believes
that is in regards to the sins of each
individual character. I mean I don't see
any other explanation. The Bible never
says or mentions that at all. But I
think it's not is a wrong premise
because we're not aligned because of the
sins. You know, that is is given too
much power or too much uh authority to a
sin. God is actually telling us that
we're being cleansed from all sins and
we're going to be transformed by the
grace of God, by the blood of Jesus,
purified and cleansed. Therefore, what's
really going to be the characteristics
of those that are redeemed is going to
be the characteristics of Jesus in their
lives, in their character.
The uh the I believe that in Revelation
7 when it speaks of the 12 tribes,
it's speaking of the good
characteristics of them. As a matter of
fact, there's a tribe that is not
mentioned in there.
Uh actually, two tribes that are not
mentioned. And pastor, I know you
probably have studied this very well. So
I'm going to give you continue with
this. But really the tribes that are not
missing are are those that you know is
Dan the tribe of Dan which was a tribe
that did not you know believe or did not
want to be part of the judgment of the
Lord is that they thought that they were
better than themselves than than anybody
else. And and this is kind of the aspect
of why they're excluded. So I believe
that if they were going to be if we were
going to be according to our sins that
should be included in the tri in the
list but because of the fact that we're
not going to be aligned by our sins but
by what Christ has done in our lives and
the characteristics of victory that
these 12 individuals of the tribe tribes
have is really what's going to make us
be part of one tribe or the other.
Yeah, correct. I I wouldn't say that we
will enter through this gates of heaven
because of the sins of the tribes of
Israel.
I do believe even though it is not
exactly clear in the Bible that there
might be some similarities between their
characters and our characters
and um some of us might be more like
Judah, some of us might have the
struggles more like Levi.
But the fact is that revelation 21
verse12 tells us that in the gates the
12 gates of the city were n were written
the names of the 12 tribes of the
children of Israel. It is possible I
don't have exact proof for this it is
possible that we'll enter to those 12
grades now 12 gates. Now what will what
will determine which gate I enter
through?
Well, that is not clearly answered in
the Bible and I I don't want to say
anything that is not very clearly
revealed.
I will be satisfied just entering there.
It doesn't matter through which gate.
Yeah. It seems like um like you have
really 12 personality profiles.
Correct.
Uh and uh you know you have 12
personality profiles also among the 12
apostles.
That's true. And just like you have Dan
uh in the Old Testament who was a
backbiter,
you know, because in Genesis 49 you have
the characteristics of the sons of
Jacob. Um you have also among the
disciples of Jesus a Judas who was also
a traitor and a backbiter. Mhm.
And so there seemed to be as you as you
look at the profiles of the
personalities of uh the sons of Jacob
and compare them with the profiles of
the twel apostles. There are many
parallel similarities between them.
It's not explicit as you mentioned uh in
the text you know doing a a profile
comparison between the sons of Jacob and
the twel apostles. But it's tempting to
see that uh that there are many
parallels.
Yes.
Um also uh it's important to realize
that uh we will enter uh the gates uh
not by the sinful profiles that we have
which you mentioned uh only overcomers
enter. Yes.
Will enter there. He who overcomes it
says in the in the seven churches after
each church. Um, and so it must be the
personality profiles
of the sons of Jacob
because they overcame.
Amen.
In other words, God doesn't look at them
as they were when they sold Joseph.
He looks at them in the context of the
entire life and the victory that they
had. Uh, that's the character profile
because God would not immortalize sin on
the gates of the city. That's right.
You wouldn't even have memory of sin. I
mean, why would you be, you know,
because I was a liar, I'm gonna go with,
you know, I don't know, one of them, 12.
So, I believe that it's more in regards,
as you mentioned, pastor, the redeeming
aspects of what the Lord has done and
and perhaps there's personalities and
whatnot. I think that maybe Genesis 49
kind of help will help us understand
even more the characteristics of of
victory. You know, as Jacob was in his
dying bed, you know, blessing his
children, he mentions in some of them,
you know, their mistakes, but in some he
doesn't even mention the mistakes. It
always, you know, in some of them is
just a blessing. So you do have to
believe that the Lord will align you
according to what your character is
perhaps like your characteristics your
abilities perhaps but not necessarily
because of the sin specifically although
uh because again there won't be even any
memory of sin and sin is not going to be
remembered or exalted or or any you know
any aspect like that. So,
so the answer to the question is we will
not enter the gates of the new Jerusalem
according to the similarities of the
sins that we have in comparison with the
sons of of Jacob.
Uh we will enter there as overcomers.
Amen.
As not as they were, but as God saw them
uh how they could become through the
power and grace of God.
Amen.
All right. Very good. Uh we have another
question now. This is a long question
and uh it's in many ways sad also. Um
this is um an individual who is writing
I will not mention the name. Does God
call us to fast in order to purge us of
sins in our lives?
My daughter believes this is with this
with all her heart. She has been in a
cycle of unhealthy behavior when it
comes to fasts. She will fast for days
and weeks at a time, saying that God
calls her to fast because she has
exhibited gluttonous or inmperate eating
habits during the times that she is not
fasting. She even went so far as to say
that God pointed her to Jesus fast of 40
days and 40 nights in the wilderness as
an example. She is emaciated and very
thin and unhealthy. I've even taken her
to the hospital where she has been
admitted so they can get her back to
healthy blood glucose and potassium
levels. I have tried to explain to her
that this type of behavior does not
honor nor glorify God. And it is also
not a good witness to those who look at
her Christian lifestyle. Can you please
help me understand whether or not
extreme fasting is biblically based or
even if the spirit of prophecy speaks
about it in some way that I can share
with my daughter? Um this is a a sad and
tragic case. Yeah.
Uh what counsel can we give uh to this
dear person who has written to us and to
the daughter?
Yes. Very good. I've met people like
this. When I was in college, I had a
friend that for some time he was very
obsessed
with fasting and all was linked to his
spirituality.
But when you look at this in a deeper
way, there are other deeper problems
behind this which in my observation from
this question that we got uh this young
lady might be struggling with some
emotional and mental health issues. Um
it it is possible that she's struggling
with an anorexia
because of her fear of eating or eating
too much gluttonousness and interpret
eating.
But being specific to to the question
in the Bible, I grew up thinking also
that fasting was maybe to purge us from
our sins or that it was a hunger strike
to make God listen to us
because you know if we want God to
answer our prayers, let's fast and let's
pray.
But in my study of this topic of
fasting, we realize that fasting is not
a work through which I gain the merit of
God.
There is nothing good in itself in
fasting that will attract God to myself.
And now God is going to say, "Poor my
kid, he's just starving to death. Let me
answer that prayer to him." Now, what is
the purpose of fasting? Well, reasons
for fasting and I have several quotes
here that I don't have time to to
mention, but these are taken from a
chapter in councils on diet and food.
There's a whole chapter there on
fasting. There are several reasons
biblical reasons for fasting. Uh one of
them is yes to develop self-control
but not to this point. There there is a
balance. We'll come back to that.
Another one is to help
the the restoration of health. Some
people who have brought health upon them
uh sickness upon themselves because of
interpreted habits of eating and
drinking and mostly uh these are people
that uh might be overweight or people
who have high blood uh sugar or
cholesterol.
These people are not going to be
affected by fasting so much as someone
who is slender. For example, if I do
that, if I try to fast in this way, I I
will have to go to the hospital and be
admitted as well. I will disappear very
soon.
So that there is there is certain
conditions that might be benefited by
certain fasts than others. Also
to
understand scripture better. uh brief
periods of fasting,
let's say a day or just skipping a meal
or pastor bore has the habit of not
eating before preaching. Right.
Right.
So that he can have his mind more clear
to understand the god's word and to
preach. That is a good thing
when we need divine help. Now in this it
is not that again that we we we fast and
it is only when we fast that God hears
us. No, when we fast we're forgetting
other things.
that are distracting us from our
connection with God. And this is a way
in which we can connect with God better.
Our minds are more clear because we're
not eating and therefore our connection
with God can be deeper in that sense.
But
and that it is not meritorious.
Right.
Now and also to obtain wisdom from God
in in the same sense. Now the Ellen
White does say also that those who fast
they need to consider their own health
and constitution. Mhm.
So, we should not go to these extremes.
And I remember I met someone that wanted
to do the same thing that Jesus did.
Fasting straight 40 days and 40 nights
only drinking a little bit of water, not
even juices because Jesus is our
example. So, I don't think this is
actually what Jesus meant. uh the length
of fasting on Jesus. Ellen White says is
that because we were so slave of
appetite and so degraded that it took
Jesus 40 days to overcome to teach us to
overcome appetite because where sin
started then redemption starts.
But the length of Jesus's fast is only
in proportion to how degraded was
humanity during those 4,000 years. It is
not a rule for us that we need to now
fast 40 days and 40 nights.
Very good answer.
The Lord actually Christ himself was
concerned with people when they would
overextend their fasting. In other
words, if you go to Matthew 15:32,
just so you know, we can see that Christ
is not advocating prolonged periods of
fasting. He actually said this. Then
Jesus called his disciples unto him and
said,"I have compassion of the multitude
because they continue with me now three
days and have nothing to eat. And I will
not send them away fasting lest they
faint in the way." So Christ performed
the miracle of feeding them, providing
to their needs because they had been
already with him. They had heard the
gospel. They had been hearing the
preaching for three days almost without
food or very little food. And therefore
Christ wanted to make sure that we
understand that he's not necessarily
asking us to have a prolonged period of
fasting. I believe that he himself said
look I don't want to send them you know
away hungry. I don't want to send them
to you know fasting and then fade the
way let me send them with food. And so
when Christ speaks in Mark or in Matthew
in regards to developing a type of faith
through prayer and fasting and that's
one of one of the verses people use to
say to say I have to fast. I have to,
you know, be able to develop my faith, I
have to do fasting. He's not speaking of
a prolonged fasting. He's not speaking
of something that you have to do as you
mentioned to get the merit of God. but
really to put your mind into harmony
with God and if you do short periods of
fasting or a you know where there's a
day if you decide to do that uh uh like
Christ even gave the the Jews nation a
day of fasting in the day of um
atonement you know that day of atonement
they could not eat it was only a day and
it was just for them to really have um
period of reflection of searching in
their hearts and coming to the Lord with
humility and humbleness. And that's
really what maybe God is saying when he
speaks of we need to have the faith but
it's only through prayer and fasting but
it's not a prolonged fasting and is not
uh speaking of of something that fasting
will actually make you better or holier.
Correct.
And and Isaiah 58
teaches us what the true fast is. The
principle behind Isaiah 58
is that true fast is denying ourselves
of certain things so that we can help
others.
Absolutely.
Ellen White says that the true fast and
joined to us today is that is to be
abstained from things that are harmful
and to use judiciously those things that
are healthy. So our healthy lifestyle
that is a kind of fast as well. Just one
more one more point here. when Jesus
uh was asked why his disciples didn't
fast and why the disciples of John
fasted. This is the answer that Jesus
gave. And there will be a time when we
will be forced to fast as as in the
times of the disciples, the apostles. In
Matthew 9:15 says, "And Jesus said to
them, can the friends of the bridegroom
mourn as long as the bridegroom is with
them? But the days will come when the
bridegroom will be taken away from them
and then they will fast." Mhm.
So notice that this is actually the
result when the bridegroom will be taken
away from them. Their sadness was going
to be so much that they would not even
have appetite and then they will fast.
You know the days will come when we will
go through severe trial and tribulation.
Uh prophecy tells us that there is a
time of trouble coming upon us. Uh we
will we will fast during those days.
During those time there will be
sometimes we won't have any food. But
this is not something enjoying us. This
is be the result of deep anguish.
Yeah.
Deep um tri trial, persecution.
So this is what I believe the Bible
teaches.
The bottom line is that um when Jesus
fed the 5000,
they were not thinking of food.
I mean, the the words that Jesus spoke
was for them
were food for their soul.
Yeah. But Jesus in his compassion said,
'Well, I've given the food that doesn't
perish. Now I'm going to give them the
food that perishes.
Yeah.
Now, let me read those two statements
that you were referring to Isaiah 58 and
the quotation from councils and diet and
foods. Ellen White said, "The true
fasting which should be recommended to
all is abstinence from every stimulating
kind of food and the proper use of
wholesome simple food which God has
provided in abundance. It's not
depriving yourself of food, but eating
the right food and discarding the wrong
food.
Right.
Isaiah 58. Is this not the fast that I
have chosen to loose the bonds of
wickedness, to undo the heavy burdens,
to let the oppressed go free, and that
you break every yoke? Is it not that you
share your bread with the hungry, and
that you bring to your house the poor
who are cast out? When you see the
naked, that you cover him and not hide
yourself from your own flesh. Practical
godliness,
amen,
is spoken of as fasting, depriving
yourself of things,
amen,
for the benefit of others.
Amen.
And partaking of the nutritious food
that God has given
and keeping away from everything that is
detrimental to health.
Yes.
Uh we think of fasting as not eating.
There are different kinds of fast.
There's juice fasting. There's water
only fasting. There's uh eating uh good
healthy food and discarding the bad
food.
Intermittent fasting.
Yeah, intermittent fasting. So, well,
our time is up. Uh thank you for joining
us. God bless you. We hope to see you in
our next program. God bless.
[Music]